devant nous il ya deux défis très
importants mais à un niveau d'inégalité
qui a vraiment augmenté avec la crise
sanitaire et donc je dirais qu'il ya une
première priorité qui est immédiate qui
aurait dû d'ailleurs être une priorité
déjà l'année dernière ces deux de
soutenir davantage les plus précaires
donc là de suspendre cette réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage parce qu'on
n'est pas encore du tout dans un moment
de reprise et d'un moment où les choses
s'améliorent pour les demandeurs
d'emploi et puis par ailleurs en quelque
chose de très important qui est de
revaloriser l'image sociaux et de les
étendre notamment de les étendre en
direction des jeunes mans puisque on a
vu que des jeunes précaires et des
jeunes étudiants se trouvaient à
demander l'aide alimentaire donc il ya
ces réformes qui sont importantes et
urgentes
et puis je dirais pour la reprise il est
très important non pas seulement
d'investir dans la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi
d'investir dans les créations d'emploi
et dans les créations d'emplois dont la
société a besoin donc des emplois dans
les services publics dans la transition
écologique et puis dans le soutien aussi
aux secteurs qui doivent se reconvertir
certains qui sont en difficulté
aujourd'hui comme l'automobile
l'aéronautique enfin voilà donc là il ya
vraiment des défis majeurs et c'est
effectivement pas simplement en formant
les demandeurs d'emploi que l'on
résoudra ces questions de la reprise de
la transition écologique et puis je
dirais de de l'économique des demandes
[Musique]